good afternoon everyone and welcome to
the last session of the day at least
here
uh my name is maria jannelli and i work
at the american museum of natural
history in new york city
and before we get started i just want to
bring your attention to the questions
that are up here on the screen you also
have a copy of them in front of you
for the next hour or so the focus of my
presentation and my colleague jennifer's
presentation
will be around these guiding questions
so we ask that you just keep them in
mind as we progress through our
presentations
and i'm going to
talk a little bit about how folks at
amnh have kept these questions in mind
as we've developed courses for coursera
so i have lessons and i have questions
for you
so amnh has developed three courses on
coursera's platform the first is
genetics and society a course for
educators the second is the dynamic
earth of course for educators and the
third is evolution of course for
educators and you may have gotten the
theme here
we build courses that are in the teacher
professional development track
that coursera offers so all three of our
courses are really professional
development courses for science teachers
and this is the basic structure of a
course
we have a content strand and we have a
practice strand and the content strand
of the course consists of videos essays
quizzes and one of our co-instructors is
a museum scientist
and on the practice side we have videos
assignments and classroom resources and
the other co-instructor is a science
teacher so that's the model that we have
for all three courses
despite the fact that every course has
colon a course for educators we did not
get just educators in our courses
in fact
almost 60 of the people in our courses
were not teachers
which was a little surprising to us
so the data you're looking at here
represents three courses offered twice
so in six offerings uh 42 percent of our
students
were were teachers and the rest were not
and interestingly that number pretty
much holds up for all of our courses in
every single course between 39 and 43
percent of our
our students were teachers and everybody
else was not but on the right you see
the breakdown for how long people have
been teaching and that's a pretty even
split across the options from
pre-service to 20-year veterans so we
have a nice mix of teachers in our
classrooms
so we didn't get our target audience
nevertheless teachers are the target
audience for the museum
so the big questions intention and
motivation we're all trying to figure
out why are people coming here what
makes them stay even worse what makes
them leave and we're trying to figure
that out for our teacher audience
and we do this by asking pre-course
surveys and post-course surveys in all
of our courses and we know that most of
the respondents took one of our courses
to deepen their content knowledge and to
access the museum's material and that's
true regardless of whether or not they
were teachers
some of our teachers did take the course
to earn pd credit but most did not take
it for that reason
and many people reported that they did
not take the course to connect with
others which made us feel good because
we could worry less about the forums and
the inactivity that was happening there
people weren't there to talk to each
other
and then you can see a quote from one of
our surveys from someone who said i
really love the course but i'm not
participating
i just want the essays
and so
we know that we have a mix of people who
are taking our courses and we're trying
to address
the motivations of of all of them
keeping our eye on the prize for us
which is that teacher audience
so after that we ran our first course we
looked at data and then we ran our
second course and we looked at data and
when we ran our third course and looked
at the data we realized that we had
three funnels and this funnel
appears in all of our courses and and in
our own meetings we just call it the
funnel effect but it's useful for us to
to use as a metaphor when we talk about
the data
so again this is data for six courses
and on the left you have the people in
the course and on the right you have
what they're doing
and total enrolled is like 62 000 but we
all know that's a meaningless number
most of those people never really show
up
and then i have peak enrollment and
enrollment at the end of the course and
those don't matter anymore because
coursera has stopped tracking them when
they were tracked
those were in line
in that hierarchy they were after
enrolled and then enrollment at the end
was after the peak
and then we have active users and that's
just people who log into the course and
we don't really know what they do
because they don't watch videos they do
something but it's not watch videos
and then at the end we have a metric
that we call amnh active and that's
people who actually watch a video
so those are the bottom two are the
people
we're really trying to capture because
they're doing something in the course
so we have the enrollment numbers but we
don't really think about engagement in
that way
and then on the right of course we have
unique video views and that's the high
number for everybody in every course
that's what people are there to do but
our essays are fifty percent video and
fifty percent s uh fifty percent essay
um so we wanted to know are people
reading these essays and they are it's
the second
most popular activity after watching
videos so that was good for us to know
because then we could put more time and
resources into writing more essays
the next we have quizzes we have one
quiz a week in each four-week course so
it's four total
forum participation is low and there's
only one course in which we have a forum
post that is required for a grade so
this statistic doesn't surprise us given
that most people aren't coming into the
course to meet new people and to connect
with other educators
and then of course at the bottom we have
people who complete the assignment and
people who enroll in signature track
so what are some of our assessment
outcomes when we dive into this data a
little bit
this is a list of metrics we look at for
one course this is our evolution course
so who was graded and who earned a
statement of accomplishment and then we
get those low percentages that everybody
gets
you know
what percentage of people got a
certificate who were enrolled in the
course and it's like four and we're
supposed to feel good about four but we
look at the two at the bottom
the percentage of students who submitted
the quiz in the first week and went on
to earn a certificate and the percentage
of people who did the assignment earned
a certificate
so we know we give the assignment in
week two the people who complete the
assignment in that week are pretty
likely to stick around and finish the
course with us and for this course it
was almost 90 percent
so those are the people we really want
to go after and engage in our
conversations in the post-course survey
and in follow-up afterward
so we also look at
content outcomes
and we also look at
practice so for the content what i have
here is a screenshot of a facebook post
so this is again from the evolution
course somebody went out and made a
facebook page for the students a bunch
of people signed up and there was a lot
of communication here and one of our
quizzes involved a photo of an
evolutionary tree and we asked a
question about it
and you see the image of the
evolutionary tree there
and the lines that you see in black
are from the quiz
but all of the red circles and
annotations are from the student and the
student was struggling and needed help
and so
this in this case it's a woman so she
downloaded
the the image saved it edited it herself
in her own software and then uploaded it
to facebook with this question and there
were 30 or 40 responses with other
people who did the same thing
downloading the image editing it their
own ways and kicking it back up so this
is an example of people actually
wrestling with the content in a way that
we could see and and keep in mind as we
consider offering the course in the
future
so what does assessment look like on the
practice side
uh this is a question we had posted in
the forum from a teacher who was asking
permission to use one of our essays
in her own science class so this is
evidence for us that people are taking
the material that we're providing and
using it with their own students which
is something we hoped that they would do
in this teacher professional development
course
and then another outcome of practice we
have is a personal email that was sent
to dr kinsler who teaches our earth
course and the earth course is the one
that has the required forum component we
ask people to go out into the field in
their own neighborhoods select a local
geologic feature take photos of it post
those to the forum and write a
description it's part one of a two-part
assignment and dr kinsler models this
assignment in a video that is shot in
central park where she's looking at a
particular rock formation near the
museum
and she got this email from a teacher
who said usually when i when i get to
this unit i take all my kids to the
museum and we go to the hall of gems and
minerals and this time i took them to
central park and i did with them what
you did for us
um and so that was a really really
powerful outcome for us we got a
follow-up email afterward um after the
the trip to central park was over and
the teacher said you know thank you so
much because i saw you do this for us i
realized that i didn't have to be a
geologist to do it with my own students
so that's another example of how the
material we're providing is turning
around into teacher practice
last two slides so in our post
post-course survey we ask
how do you plan to use the following
course materials in your own classrooms
and we have essays videos
the assignment and classroom resources
and this just lets us know you know what
do people think they will do with the
material we've given them and what we're
in the process of doing now is a
follow-up survey saying
have you actually used any of this if so
how and we're asking people's permission
to contact them
either via email or on the phone to talk
to them a little bit more and learn
about if and how they're using our
material and all of this information
will help us
improve the the courses that we're going
to be offering in the future and help us
to better design new courses that um are
kind of on on the road map for us
so these are the what these are some of
the ways we've thought about engagement
and how to meet our learners where they
are how to find out where they come from
and see where they hope to be and try to
find a middle balance i'm going to turn
it over now to my colleague jennifer
who's going to talk a little bit about
some of the work that she's been doing
similar theme different area
all right so just to reiterate the
guiding questions
that sort of unite both our
presentations and the discussion we hope
to engender afterwards um what's the
background other information about your
learners and why is it important uh to
know how will you obtain that
information and what will you do to meet
your learners where they are
my name is jennifer devore and i am
currently in a job transition i've been
a postdoc at the mit teaching and
learning lab for the past two years and
i'll start as faculty at purdue
in about six days
so
i'm excited for a number of reasons but
one of those is that we're using some
online
modules in a blended environment
in that classroom so
i'm eager to continue some of this
research and see
what plays out in terms of meeting
students where they're at and trying to
support them
in their learning goals
i'm happy to be here with the director
of the teaching learning lab lori
breslow who will help maria and i
facilitate the discussion of course with
maria and with all of you i'm eager to
hear about your experiences as
practitioners in a number of different
contexts
and what you do who your learners are
etc
i'm going to focus on in particular on
two factors in this whole array of
characteristics that describe where
students are and these are language and
location
this is in part because of my interest
as an international and comparative
education researcher
but also because we show empirically
that these are important for student
learning
so again with the guiding questions that
you have in front of you i'll give you
some of the findings from our particular
example study looking at who our
students are how we got that information
why it was important for learning and
what might be done to individualized
learning both the possibilities and
what's actually
being done in moot classrooms
um again in order to better understand
our learners and meet them where they're
at we need to determine what factors
matter in that interaction between a
virtual classroom and the real world
context so as i mentioned in our study
we focus on the factors of language and
geographic location and we use both
analysis of variance and regression
modeling to empirically look at the
relationships between these background
off-platform characteristics and
students performance in terms of their
final grade in the mooc classroom
in the research that i'm focusing on
today we ask first how do language and
location characteristics interact with
moderate mediate
the relationship uh with other
characteristics such as student
behaviors on the platform
and then is there a significant
relationship between language and
location two important background
characteristics and students achievement
in this class and this is with the the
larger
goal of understanding implications for
using knowledge of students background
information in moocs
for both course design running courses
and and more extensively for policy
decisions
the specific analysis that we conducted
uses data from one particular course
but we have some anecdotal evidence from
feedback from collaborators that our
findings might apply more broadly
and of course i'd be interested in
hearing during our discussions whether
these findings do or don't apply in your
own context
the data that we use come from the first
mooc that was offered by mit on the edx
platform i ran from march to june in
2012 and was a circuits and electronics
course normally geared towards uh
sophomores uh in uh course six which is
uh electrical engineering and computer
science and taught in this building
you can see a small screen grab from
that particular course
we had a number of different sources of
information from which we could directly
glean or infer background information
as well as observe student behaviors and
performance on their assessments in the
class
the sources of our data include click
stream data from which we can glean
students ip addresses and therefore
infer their geographic location we can
look at their behaviors and every single
click that they make on the platform
to see how they're using course
resources like homework problems videos
and that also provided us information on
their profiles there was a profile page
they could fill out
and so that's where we saw a
self-identified language information
in addition we had the text of all the
discussion forum uh participation so we
could see not only whether students
posted but what they were posting we
could see their their words
and for a limited group of students we
had an end of course survey that
provides more information on who they
are so where they're from
educational and home background
factors like that
so i'll start
in light of these guiding questions
thinking about
who were the students and what
information we have with a focus on
language as a characteristic
so in the student profile which was
filled out by the vast majority of
students one of the fields that they
could use to describe themselves was
language that's all they said it was an
open
ended response form
while a notable
minority of students put two or more
languages down in that field we focused
on the first language that was listed
for all of the students who responded
these were the top 12 language groups
and although english which is the
language of the class was a notable
majority of students reporting that
first
over 15 percent of them uh reported
spanish then you can see portuguese the
languages and dialects of south asia
and there is a notable falloff of course
after english
but we have to remember that in the mooc
context these small percentages still
mean a large number of students so this
is a percentage out of 108 000 students
who are clicking on the site
and still there's almost 10 percent of
the students whose languages aren't even
listed here
um so looking at the the myriad
languages that were reported uh pushed
us to go the next step and look at the
broader linguistic context and the
interaction between these two factors
and interestingly while this was a class
that was entirely in english the
majority of students in the course were
located by ip addresses in non-english
predominant countries those kind of
sparked our interests and we went
another step further to see if there
were significant differences in
performance and behavior between four
groups of students
and these were on the upper left
students who reported english first and
were in a predominantly english-speaking
country
students who reported english first and
were not in uh in english country
students who reported another and
another language first but were in a
predominantly english-speaking country
and finally students who reported
another language and were in a
non-english country
um interestingly we found
significant differences in both
performance and behavior we can see
notably higher performance
for students in non-english countries
and the highest for students who
while they're in a non-english country
they're saying they're reporting english
first as their language
in addition there are differences in how
students are using the learning
materials between these four groups
so note that of students who report
another language but are in
predominantly english countries they
have the lowest number of homework
attempts
while students who report another
language and are in a non-english
country have the highest number of
homework attempts
and as we might expect students who
report another language have the lowest
average number of discussion forum posts
which are often but not always conducted
in english while interestingly those
high achieving students in non-english
speaking countries who report english on
their profile have the highest number of
discussion forum posts so we found some
significant significant differences both
in performance and in how students were
using the platform by language so now
let's look at one more factor that we
investigated to understand where our
learners are and how to meet them in
this case literally where the students
are geographically speaking
i won't go into a lot of the other work
that we've done on country factors such
as income level
but we'll focus here on urbanicity city
size and student mobility
for individual students but i do want to
acknowledge that there are a number of
factors that go along with the
geographic context that we have found to
be important and again we identified
students
via their ip addresses and noted where
they most frequently
logged in from and also were able to
match that with a city size database
participants
and in particular high performers are
concentrated in large urban centers
overall being in a larger city was not
related to higher achievement once you
control for behaviors and other student
background factors
however in certain locations and indeed
these were
in countries with major urban spaces and
a notable rural urban divide there was a
strong relationship a positive
relationship between city size being in
a large urban center and grade in the
class
you can see student clusters of students
in our heat map of student login
locations you can see a concentration in
urban centers for example the east coast
of the u.s
and i want to note that we found
students from nearly every country in
the world but the dots also correspond
to the number of students logging on
from cities
so you can't really see a number of uh
the the cities that are actually on here
for example you see a large dot in cape
town south africa but much smaller dots
in the rest of the country
but further complicating our
measurement and
issues of understanding our learners as
students are want to do they don't
always behave in a nice neat easy to
easy to measure way and they're very
mobile
a small percentage of students access
the site from multiple countries
and if we zoom in
we can see that a notable percentage
accessed the site from multiple cities
within the same country
so this might uh lead us to infer that
our students are it's a particular kind
of student
over 30 percent accessing from multiple
locations a highly mobile group
that might already have access to the a
global community
and we did indeed find notable
differences in the types of resources
used by those students who are logging
on from multiple cities and multiple
countries for example in terms of the
proportional use of resources you see
those students who are travelers so to
speak we find them in more than one city
they're using the lecture video much
less in terms of their overall
proportional use of the site
which makes sense
lecture videos require a consistent
connection for to be able to be streamed
on the other hand those travelers are
spending more of their time
proportionally speaking on the homework
which we've shown in other work to be
related to higher achievement
and so being a traveler was related to
being a higher achieving student
so to summarize
both language and location were
important predictors of achievement
they're important for student learning
what does that mean
for these factors
indicating how we can meet our learners
where they are so for example with
language we can think about presenting
uh information uh via multiple modes so
a best practice in teaching and learning
anyways and to a certain extent this was
done in the class so
the lecture videos were juxtaposed with
the running transcript of what was being
said
in the videos but this is something that
can be
extended even further
location
was also an important characteristic we
need to recognize that internet
connectivity is an issue
in a number of contexts
and again there are other factors
besides these two that we know
from some of our other work that are
important for achievement in the mooc
space
so more broadly some of the implications
of our work looking at the relationship
between background factors and
achievement
first we want to gather individual
student background information from the
beginning of the course so for example a
pre-course survey instrument we want to
identify important ways that individual
characteristics fit into context so the
example of language it's not only the
individual students language but what
that means in the broader linguistic
context of that country
and finally we want to scaffold the
learning opportunities for students
within that thinking about student
getting students from where they're at
academically to that next step
and the ways that we can actually serve
the intended learning outcomes of the
mooc
so with that i'm going to
finish and i look forward to
hearing about your experiences in the
discussion that we're going to have so
i'll invite maria up
i'll remind everyone of the guiding
questions
and we're going to
explain the discussion that we have
structured for you now um so this was at
the request of the the conference
organizers
they asked for the last 40 minutes of
our time together to be devoted to a
discussion
um so we want this to be as interactive
as possible so
if you want to explain what we're going
to do sure so for the next two minutes
we want you to just
take some time and think about how these
guiding questions apply to the work
you're doing
and we want you to think about
challenges
ideas
and
most importantly solutions because we're
interested in hearing about how you've
met some of the challenges
and then after that two minutes we'd
like you to get together in groups of
two to three whoever's nearby you and
just share what you're doing
in your own universities or museums or
other organizations
what your role is and
how you've thought about these three
guiding questions and we'll meet in
those small groups for 10 minutes and
then come back and ask
somebody from from your group uh to
share with the rest of us
um so we'll start now so take a minute
to just either
quietly reflect or jot down some of your
own ideas and then we'll let you know
when to break into groups
we'll leave the discussion structure up
and we'll bring you one of these
mom
so if you haven't already joined a group
or met your neighbor go ahead and do
that it's 4 31 you'll have until about 4
41 to discuss these questions
um
yes
it's
oh
great
yes
oh
is
yes
foreign
we have about five more minutes
parker
foreign
okay
is
yes
video
foreign
please
so take take one minute to wrap up your
thoughts
oh yeah yeah you want to grab one and
then
all right so uh let's come together as a
large group uh you have you've had the
chance
to reflect a little bit about your own
experience
maria and i were talking before the
session and it's not often that we get
the chance to reflect on
the experiences especially in
a pretty fast-paced field right now
and you've also gotten the chance to
talk to one or two other people about
their experiences
and in the remaining time we'd love to
hear from each group
in particular we'd like to hear maybe
some illuminating stories so what was
something that struck you in your
conversations and what were some perhaps
challenges that that you faced but uh as
maria said what were some solutions that
that you found that that worked or um
maybe didn't work as well but that's a
learning experience that the the rest of
the the crowd can can have so
maybe let's just start over here and we
can go around to each group if you want
to
share out to the entire audience
well joe and i are sort of on the
opposite ends of our sorry could you uh
tell everyone who you are as well
i'm michael
i'm from columbia x
and uh excuse my voice
joe and i seem to be right now at
opposite ends of sort of mooc
construction joe is constructing a
computer science mooc i'm constructing a
history mooc
so the idea of
creating this environment where what are
we looking for or what are we trying to
um
structure it so our learners are are
able to
do well in that course and joe was
mentioning that what's really important
is um
knowing the state of knowledge that the
students are at when they enter this
course that requires math and other
programming
as well as you know their educational
background
and for me it's more you know how do i
create this environment where students
how do i create assessments that would
be a little bit above just your normal
say true and false multiple choice how
do i get students in history class
especially the history of the united
states u.s civil war how do we have
debate and discussion that doesn't fly
off the rail at the same time uh you
know allows students to really engage so
that's a
different kind of problem that i'm
having compared to joe
we worried about that
we worried about that fly off the rail
problem particularly with our evolution
course we weren't sure how the
discussion space was going to go
and we were really really pleased that
we only had to block one student
so so i hope you have that kind of
success
i'm gonna go to that side yeah
so is this group here
whoever wants to share
am i really the representative
elected yeah
i i really haven't had the chance uh to
i will
to uh collect our collective ideas i'm
cormac mcgrath from karolinska
instituted together with
gerhardt sonnet harvard university and
jackie from smithsonian
so the conversation we talked about
several things but the conversation i
think boiled down to
and correct me if i misrepresent you
some of our courses are coming
from campus
so it's courses that may be given on
campus at
karolinska is a prestigious medical
university in europe harvard obviously
and
smithsonian
as well even though it's not a
university so how do we provide courses
that are true to the nature of the
university but at the same time opening
them up to
the man on the street and that's a
different aspect of language i think
than than perhaps the one that we
addressed earlier
which looked more at mother tongue
language
so that's that's kind of the
conversation we were having and we would
love to talk more about it
along those lines
thus far
bridging that gap between
the university and its uh sort of
institutional identity and the broader
participants in the mooc space
hi i'm ellen netty from the
international monetary fund we have
some of the same issues we
teach applied economics and finance to
government officials people who work for
their central banks and finance
ministries so we really targeted the
content of our courses towards that
audience
but we wanted to open this up to the
general public as well and we're still
analyzing the data from our first mooc
so we don't have i don't have the
answers yet but
um you know we're wondering whether we
should as we design courses going
forward whether we should have
more opportunities to go more in depth
if if it you know if if they're members
of our target audience or have a
stronger background you know do we can
we somehow build another track in i mean
the idea was that we would
invest the resources to target this you
know traditional audience and then
hopefully the marginal cost of opening
it up to the world wouldn't be too high
but we're thinking about whether there
are ways we can customize
the content so that we can meet the
needs of both audiences because i think
they are a bit different
there's another comment to follow up
right here
hi laura weiner from mcgill university
and our courses were very general public
which meant that we had people you know
who were in high school to you know
retired chemistry profs and the first
course was in chemistry
so one of the things we did for that was
in every single section
if you want to know more and had paths
off so that people could kind of branch
and come back but it wasn't central
so the central core was actually fairly
you know narrow in a sense but i think
that that's a way of
of allowing people to
to explore what they're interested in
and without having to do so much that it
would turn you off
any volunteers
hi this is el wang from columbia
teachers college um
so our group had a really nice
discussion um
and the first question we wanted to ask
ourselves before we ask
what kind of information we need to
collect from our learners is why do we
care about it do we care about whether
our learners are happy or not since it's
free what is responsibilities
of our faculty instructors to make sure
we have as many happy learners as
possible
and that really
prompted us to think about
the different types of learners we have
and how to
assess them
according to their specific need
especially giving attention between the
traditional online learners and the
special mood learners for example
we noticed that
for well i myself was also part of a
moot instruct instructor team and also a
researcher myself
we noticed that some of our learners
they would in the first week download
all of our videos and learning materials
and we just go back and never come back
to the main courser interface
and we were lucky to know some of the
people in
who are colleagues of ours so we can
substantiate that actually happened and
they're actually happy learners but if
we were not you know acquaintances to
each other how would we go to get the
data to say that that's part of the
benefit of our moocs so information
hidden like that
the so-called fragmented
data
how do we go to
collect that data
to tell us like
what we can do
as faculty instructors to do better or
designers to
change anything or even for investors to
say whether they wanted to or they need
to invest again for the same type of
moocs
yeah that's an interesting point we have
this really
rich and vibrant uh huge amount of data
but still we're missing some pieces that
we've we've seen as students move
between the platform and off platform
another response over here
yeah i'm joe warren from rice university
actually she made an interesting comment
about happy learners we we teach a class
and we don't have happy students
actually the the students that go
through the class i think learn a lot
now i don't know if i could prove that
you know if you put me to it but i'll
give you an example you talked about
your students went to your class they
downloaded material and disappear so we
make our students unhappy and we dull it
out a week at a time so it's very much a
cohort style system and the reason we do
that is because
the experts that want to take the class
because it's maybe status or they're
brushing up some like that we force them
to come back to class over and over
because they would love to grab all our
material and problems and disappear and
go off and do in their class but they
come back and as a result
there's a significant mentoring of the
strong students answering forum posts
things like that where those students
actually turn out to be a giant asset to
the class so that's an example of where
we do something that doesn't make the
students happy but i think it yields a
better learning experience
um oh bring them back down just a quick
question um for show of hands
um in thinking about the third question
and listening to what some of you have
said so far i'm wondering
if you got this information in real time
if you could know who your learners were
at your organizations do you actually
have the capacity to change your course
design while it's live or is this more
of a reflective process where you hope
to be able to apply it in the future so
capacity to edit on the fly
i think the capacity i don't think
that's the way to go
really in terms of capacity to edit on
the fly because you'll never have that
bandwidth you'll never have it and from
one course to the next it'll always be
different
and i think
a more productive way to go is really
trying to create
structures that the students bring a lot
of themselves to
so that they're bringing their problems
to it so the instructional design is
where you have to do that prep work up
front
i think in terms of saying okay this is
going to be your the assignment is we
want you and you have to think about
what the learning outcomes then are we
want the students to develop certain
analytical skills so do you really care
about the specific problem that they're
applying it to probably not so much so
if you structure the
task
so that it's
the students can bring themselves to the
task then you don't have to try
and anticipate all that variety
it's requisite variety you know we'll
never have the variety if there's 20 000
of them we don't have 20 000 people
yeah so you you asked about
changing content on the fly um and this
is a nice segue just into our groups
kind of discussion
um so my name is tim moorey and i work
for johnson johnson for a medical device
company that's part of johnson johnson
and we're experimenting with edx to
transform the way we educate
our surgeon customers mostly surgeons
so you talked about your courses that
are designed specifically for teachers
and then you've got some non-teachers in
your course we designed our first course
for surgeons
and also of course got some non-surgeons
in the course but one thing we did was
beta test
one week's worth of content with our
intended audience so we got a group of
surgeons beta tested our content with
them and that led us to to make a pretty
significant change so
um
the thing that we did is is so this
first course was about weight loss
surgery and it was basically telling
bariatric surgeons weight loss surgeons
that what they think they know about the
surgery and how it works is actually
kind of wrong based on some some
research that we've uh
that we've initiated
um
so we
most surgeons have like a powerpoint
type slide deck that they do when they
do kind of community outreach stuff when
they have patients coming and and
considering weight loss surgery and so
our activity that we proposed was to
have them as they worked through our
content we would have them pause every
you know three to four little mini
lectures and and then construct some
powerpoint slides that they would then
hopefully use in their practice and we
thought pedagogically makes total sense
um when we asked them to do that and we
beta tested it with them they all
unanimously just not only disliked it i
would say despised the idea that we were
actually going to ask them to like put
some effort into the into the course
it was
he was the brain the brains behind it so
you can credit him with a great idea and
we loved it too but our surgeons hated
that idea and so we based on that we i
mean
it was a small uh beta test but it was
so overwhelming that we made the change
um they just didn't like they said look
i've already got slides if i want to
create new slides i'll do that on my own
time i don't need you telling me to that
i need to go do this
it's yeah i mean so you asked about the
background of our audience
they're they're they are their own
animals for sure
what we did instead is we basically
constructed the slides
for them and then gave them at the end
of each week as as rewards
that's a good idea
also his grip so i have to credit nathan
with the good ideas but yeah
we have we have
we have a but we only have a couple more
minutes um so there are a few last
groups who maybe didn't share if you
have any brief thoughts that you want to
share with everyone
on the front and then here yeah
i'm renee kazot from stanford
uh we talked with quentin uh from csel
uh about the first question uh what
background and other information is good
to collect and uh i suppose in terms of
sharing something important in a short
amount of time we found at stanford that
actually giving out a pre-course survey
before the course or right when the
course starts is not as good as giving
it a little bit later in because a lot
of the people who start right at the
beginning
they just explore
and they are gone very soon and you end
up not having data for a lot of the
people you really care about who stay in
the course who join a little bit later
another point uh
is we got some bad feedback on some of
the demographic questions so especially
when we ask for uh wraith and race and
ethnicity uh which in the literature and
education has been very important
variables to look at
some people responded very badly to that
also in terms of psychology and
stereotype threat one might even imagine
that asking for gender
right could could
activate certain
threats for females especially when
taking courses in the engineering space
so these are i think some important
questions to to think about when we
collect our data and how we do it and
what effects measurements might have
i think we'll probably have to wrap up i
know that there's a lot of uh additional
discussion that we can have about those
questions and a number of the questions
that that everyone's raised here but um
i want to um thank all of you and
my co-presenter and lori and the
conference folks
for a fascinating hour that you've spent
with us and so i think as per kalyan's
instructions
head out that way so thank you